so i've been asking this of everyone
i've been interviewing recently and i
would love to hear
from both of you what tv series would
you love to guest star on
blacklist eddie that's john that's
john davis's show is it i would like to
guest
on uh little women of atlanta
[Laughter]
or little women of l.a no actually i
would like to be a guest on
my favorite show uh ridiculousness
really is that your favorite show i
wouldn't say it was my favorite but we
watch ridiculousness a lot
ridiculousness is the perfect show
ridiculousness is like a microcosm of
the world it's a bunch
it's like what's going on what's going
on in the world like this is what's
happening
it's these little quick snippets this is
what's happening all around the world
people are falling off stuff and running
into stuff and doing it's like it did
i love ridiculous hey steven every time
i walked in his room
ridiculousness was on even if it's just
like music even if he's not watching it
it's on in the background it's well
first of all that show airs on mtv
24 7. it doesn't stop always it's always
on
you can always it's always on and what
happens is you'll be channeled
trying to find something it's like
you're trying to find something there's
nothing on
be like hey put on ridiculous
[Laughter]
watch i'll go looking for a
ridiculousness too but when there's
nothing else on it's
it's always you can always watch reading
and and
seeing someone run into a wall never
gets old
i've watched it a lot and i could spend
the whole interview talking about this
but
jumping into uh the actual movie um the
first movie i think a lot of people
don't realize was the first time like an
african royal family was put
in a big hollywood movie it's one of the
first black romantic comedies
um the first it's the first movie with
an all-black cast
in the history of hollywood that was
successful
all around the world all around the
world
coming to america was a hit and still to
this day in 2021
it's only a handful of movies that had
all black casts
that that were success been successful
all around the world
a handful and you still have fingers
left over completely and that's what i
wanted to ask you guys
about what does the first film mean to
both of you
in terms of your careers and the social
impact of the film
it is truly the definition of a blessing
you know in the sports world it's like
saying i played for the lakers
it's just an incredible thing to be a
part of
yeah and it had a uh
like i said that it's the first movie
with an all black cast
that was successful all around the world
and uh
of all of my movies it's the only one
that became like uh
like a cult a cul has like a cult
following
you know this movie is on television all
the time
it's on the movie channels all the time
on this christmas
vh1 played it for 24 hours straight
back-to-back
and halloween they have like theme
parties some people
dress up as characters from the movie
and it's just uh
it's the only one of my movies that did
that curious for both of you
if you could have a spin-off movie about
one of the other characters you play in
the film
uh what would it be and why i would do a
spin-off on randy watson
like a like a randy watson movie this
there's a little spot that they did
amazon did this really funny spot did
you see it arsenio with
like randy watson like a comeback
concert i was like that looks like i'd
go see that movie it's like him
in concert very cool there are a couple
of those commercials amazon's doing an
incredible job
creating different ways of rolling this
out and i've seen
mock commercials that are hilarious
you'll see them eventually this movie
was made you know when we made this
movie we made this movie for
you know the be at the movie theaters
with audiences and all that then the
world fell apart
and uh it's a it's a
gift from above that we wound up at
amazon
and uh more people will see the movie
now
than if it would have came out in the
movie theaters like more people will see
it here
and uh and the way they're all the stuff
that they're doing and
to get the awareness out there is uh
everything worked out
perfect hey steven they called me and
asked me if i would do a short film
called a day in the life of morris
and i think the idea came along a little
too late but it would have been a funny
little documentary of morris the barber
i still think you need to do it and i
would watch it so when i want to see
that
100 um i have to rap already i'm just
going to say
really it was a real thrill to talk to
you both today about this film
oh thank you steve cool i wish you
nothing but the best
thank you bro thank you sir